we have done a video on the titans that
could defeat mechagodzilla
and now we are going to showcase to you
one of the kaiju from pacific rim
that would have an edge in a fight
against the mecca
these pacific rim kaiju although not
having the same hype as the classic
robot
they have combat experience against
other giant robots as well
the jaegers yeah i know mechagodzilla
and jaeger's are not a good comparison
and obviously the monsterverse mecca
is way more powerful than the latter but
anyway
there is one kaiju surprising as it is
that is powerful enough and might be
able to take down the
mecca but then again your thoughts might
be different from mine
so let's get down with this sickness yes
of course
firstly the design the titan maker
godzilla has
a series of short metal plates that
extends from the back of its neck to the
tip of its tail
similar to godzilla's dorsal plates it
has four zygodactyl claws on its hands
and its four limbs are much
bulkier and slightly longer than the
true godzilla's
a drill is mounted on the tip of the
mechagodzilla's tail
it also has shoulder mounted rocket
launchers and possesses a red energy
beam that is capable of knocking down
godzilla himself
this beam can also beam lock with and
overwhelm godzilla's atomic breath
this mechagodzilla unlike its previous
incarnations has improved physical
strength and human-like reflexes
allowing it to easily overwhelm an adult
skull crawler
as well as knock over and throw godzilla
around like a rag doll
mega godzilla was able to combine his
ability with his melee attacks to defeat
both godzilla
and kong in the final fight despite
being outnumbered
the mechagodzilla also has thrusters
mounted on its back and sides enabling
quick bursts of movement
or added momentum to its strikes and
even adding to faster defenses
on the other hand the kaiju are a
genetically modified species of
amphibious creatures created by the
precursors
a sentient rays from the antiverse the
kaiju were able to reach earth's
dimension
after the precursors open a gateway
between dimensions
a breach now the kaiju are a highly
aggressive and poisonous creature
gigantic creatures created as biological
weapons of war with the aim of
annihilating humanity
they are classified on the serizawa
scale and each kaiju is categorized
into one of five groups those in the
categories one and two are the lowest
while those
three to five are the highest so which
one of these guys you can take on the
mecha g
is it the mega kaiju is it slatten or
pacific rim the blacks copperhead or
apex
well these kaiju as powerful as they are
might not have a chance against a
superpowered robo godzilla
a couple of them might even be bigger
than size than him
notably slaaden and the mega kaiju and
the first one can even survive a nuclear
attack and the other one
can beat the crap out of several
state-of-the-art jaegers
but mechagodzilla isn't just any regular
mecca
like the pacific rim counterparts brute
force is kind of irrelevant against
something that can destroy you from
distance with a beam attack not to
mention that
mechagodzilla's brood strength is even
more powerful than
any of the kaiju's so which one
is the kaiju that would hold its ground
so in pacific rim uh the first movie in
the battle of the coast of hong kong
a couple of kaiju came out of the breach
and about four jaegers destroying two
older ones and immobilizing the other
but falling to gypsy danger
in the end in the battle despite a
two-on-one a disadvantage
utachi manages to shut down crimson thai
food and seriously wound journal alpha
with her asset
melting the heavy armor on its head and
chest
but it was nearly killed by a very
powerful state of the art jaeger called
striker eureka
while this jaeger is distracted and
giving otachi a beating of a lifetime
and being moments away from killing it
with its chess
missiles another kaiju leatherback
charges
its organic emp and fires it disabling
the jaeger
leatherback is a naturally aggressive
creature with a gorilla-like appearance
when wounded it uses hit-and-run tactics
leatherback attacks from behind using
its opponent's weight to its advantage
the hard protrusions that cover the
leather bags hands and body will slice
to
thick armor its thick skin allows it to
withstand a lot of damage and not break
down
strong shields on the shoulders as well
as prominent crests like plates that
cover the top of the head
add to this defense but the kaiju's most
lethal feature is a massive
full lobe organ on its back that has the
ability to charge and produce
a very powerful electromagnetic pulse
that disables
all electronics in a large area posing a
serious threat to digitized jaegers
and this is the advantage that it would
have against mechagodzilla who is also
basically a superpowered digitized
jaeger that looks like godzilla
leatherback if it fights against
mechagodzilla one on one or even with a
team up with otachi
would obviously be turned to bits by the
monsterverse robot
but if it fires its powerful emp that
was bioengineered
by the highly advanced precursors it has
a good chance to power down the
functioning systems
of the highly digitized mecha that was
probably
that has probably thousands of
electronic parts that would be fried up
by the emp
this will disable or even slow down the
mecha to a point where the kaiju
would be able to take it down piece by
piece little by little over time
till there is nothing left but if the
mecha maintains its distance and opens
the battle
with the proton screen beam then
leatherback doesn't have a chance
so that's that the one kaiju that would
be able to take down mechagodzilla under
certain scenarios and circumstances
anyway it's been a blast and we have
come to the end of the video
do hit that like button for support and
subscribe to be a part of the mind cue
family
and also smash that bell button for
regular updates on master videos
right here on mind cue take care fam